بقراراتها المثيره للجدل في افغانستان
وضعت حكومه طالبا نفسها امام ضغوط دوليه
هائله بسبب تضييقها على النساء ففي الوقت
الذي يستعد مجلس الامن الدولي للانعقاد
لبحث الازمه اعلنت واشنطن انها تدرس
الخيارات لدفع طالبان للتراجع عن قرار حضر
عمل الافغانيات في المنظمات غير الحكوميه
المنظمات تلعب دورا اساسيا في محاوله
معالجه واحده من اسوا الازمات الانسانيه
في العالم حيث يعيشوا سبعه 97% من الافغان
في الفقر وثلث السكان بحاجه للمساعدات
للبقاء على قيد الحياه مع مواجهه 20 مليون
شخص الجوع الشديد بحاسب المتحده تلك
المنظمات التي تعتبر حيويه وضروريه في
افغانستان مهدده بالانهيار فحضر عمل
الافغانيات ترك فجوه كبيره في الدعم
المنقذ للحياه وصفه قرارات طالبان
بالتميزيه
ايه رزق امباص بوفر استجد من المستحيل
مواصله انشطهنا اذا لم يكن لدينا موظفات
الشتاء الماضي كانت المساعدات الانسانيه
هي التي جنبت وقوع مجاعه اذا لم نتمكن من
تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه بالطريقه نفسها
فسنواجه وضع المروع للغايه اكثر من الف
ومئتين منظمه غير حكوميه تعمل في
افغانستان منها اربع منظمات دوليه كبرى
كما تعليقه عملياتها لعدم قدرتها على
اداره برامجها دون موظفات في مجالات رعايه
الصحيه والتعليم والمياه والصرف الصحي ومع
الصرار لطالبان بان المساعدات لم تتاثر
بقراراتها فستجد افغانستان التي تعتمد
بالكامل تقريبا على المساعدات نفسها امام
كارثه انسانيه ستعصف بالملايين في
المستقبل القريب رشا خياطه العربيه